it's been more than 10 years since the
original Avatar dominated the box office
with its amazing visuals and immersive
3D during the long wait for part two the
filmmakers came up with and then set
aside a sequel you'll never get to see
at least not in theaters
director James Cameron is the force
behind many iconic films from Terminator
to Titanic but the most successful is
undeniably Avatar which premiered in
2009 and swiftly became the biggest
movie ever made you know the story Jake
Sully is a former Marine who becomes
enamored with the world of Pandora in
the guise of an avatar who looks like
them he grows close with the natives the
navi and elects to help them in their
fight to defend their home from
exploitation it took years for Avatar to
become a reality and once it did it
became nothing short of a global
phenomenon it grossed billions of
dollars at the global box office and the
vast majority of audiences and critics
seemed to adore it despite that
unprecedented success it's taken more
than 10 years for the sequel Avatar the
way of water to become a reality the
long-awaited follow-up will hit theaters
on December 16 2022 intending to pave
the way for three more sequels that will
arrive in the years to come time will
tell if these films stay on track but
it's clear that James Cameron is
treating this franchise meticulously
even scrapping one sequel entirely after
he had completed the script as he
recently revealed the original concept
for Avatar 2 looked quite different from
what the way of water turned out to be
ahead of the theatrical arrival of
Avatar the way of water James Cameron
spoke to Total film about the Avatar
world and all of the work that has gone
into it along the way he touched on his
initial idea for a sequel to the 2009
sensation titled avatar The High Ground
Cameron recalled I was working with a
team of writers we had a lot of ideas we
kept trying to Corral it into a box and
it never quite fit so at a certain point
I said I'll just finish it and see if
it's a movie when it was all said and
done Cameron said the 130 page script
was excellent and told a compelling
story at the same time Cameron admits
that The High Ground script wasn't quite
up to par for reasons he couldn't quite
put his finger on he told the
publication it was missing one of those
critical elements about sequels which is
that it didn't go enough into the
unexpected the story also didn't play by
what Cameron refers to as Avatar rules
meaning it didn't quite tap into the
spiritual nature of the previous film
with that Cameron and his crew went back
to the drawing board board they
eventually landed on the concept that
became the way of water and the rest is
history let's get it done so far all we
know about Avatar The High Ground is
what James Cameron has divulged but he's
about to reveal a whole lot more as he
described to Total film there's some
great stuff in it I mean you've got the
navi fighting with bows and arrows and
zero g I want to see that movie while
you won't quite see it as a movie you
will get to see the ideas in action as
Cameron revealed we're turning it into a
dark horse graphic novel you'll be able
to see that interim battle that took
place between Movie 1 and movie 2. The
Graphic novel will arrive on December
6th 2022 just 10 days before the way of
water Premiere fans of the franchise
won't want to miss out not if they want
the full story anyway from the new film
and theaters to this scrapped sequel
seeing the light of day not to mention
the three movies still to come if the
way of water performs well it's a great
time to be an avatar fan for the first
time in quite a while
[Music]